Nia sighted mummies counting plagues
prematurely and breaking gender
stereotypes left and right things happen
so fast in the mummy you might have
missed these dates the first time around
the mummy opens with an extensive
prologue of our high priest Emma tips
backstory in ancient Egypt he had a
secret relationship with a naksuna moon
the Mistress of pharaoh seti the first
and the two of them died for their
Forbidden Love and betrayal the film is
so fun and exciting that on first
viewing you may not realize that this is
actually the only Exposition and
backstory the audience gets the mummy
largely exists in the present moment
with minimal references to the past of
other Central characters while we find
out that Evie and Jonathan carnahan's
parents died we never learn what
happened to them nor do we discover what
brought Jonathan to Egypt other than
following his sister you liked me I lied
to everybody what makes you so special
we also know nothing of Rick's past
before he joined the French Foreign
Legion and traveled to Hamunaptra with
his Garrison where he was attacked by
the Magi this lack of backstory
contributes to the fast pace of the the
film and this lighthearted comedic Vibe
the plot propels the characters forward
at a Breakneck speed so they tend to
have much time to ruminate this approach
also leaves some significance unanswered
questions on the mummy but luckily the
2001 c chord The Mummy Returns addresses
some of them in that film we learn about
Rick's mysterious tattoo in childhood in
an orphanage in Cairo as well as Evie's
past life connection to ancient Egypt
and Pharaoh cities whale Court when
Jonathan startles Evie at the museum by
hiding in a coffin with a mummy and
jumping out at her we immediately
understand the archetype he represents
he's a comic relief sidekick but after a
bit of reflection and a couple of more
viewings you might realize his first
interaction between brother and sister
teaches us much more about Jonathan than
you noticed at first first Jonathan
admits it sometimes like to join the
ranks of the Dead I wish you would do it
sooner rather than later before you ruin
my career the way you've ruined yours
this makes us wonder what exactly his
career is the film depicts him as a
professional Thief Gambler and Drinker
this interaction doesn't reveal what
Jonathan's career was but it suggests he
feels lust and like a failure he jokes
about wishing he could join the dead and
complains about finding nothing of value
and archaeological decks this plans to
see that Jonathan may have been an
egyptologist at one point although he
isn't as knowledgeable as Evie tor.com
hone didn't have Jonathan's dialogue
hints at a more tragic past given his
age in the era it's possible Jonathan
Falls in World War one and has PTSD
which has left him shell-shocked or much
like Winston of the royal Air Force
Jonathan may suffer from survivor's
guilt drowning his tormenting booze and
questionable decisions although none of
the other films in the mummy franchise
reveal anything about Jonathan's ruined
career he proves himself resourceful and
entrepreneurial throughout it's probably
best not to spend too much time tearing
his little bloodhole apart obviously the
puzzle box containing the map had to
come into Rick Jonathan and Evie's
possession for this wild adventure to
transpire and the mummy wouldn't exist
without Rick finding it but upon further
viewing did you think it was foolish or
the Magi to put them open the key and
then bury them in harmony near Emma
Temple sarcophagus
oh I'm the map it's all up here if the
Magi were trying to prevent imagep from
being resurrected why didn't they
separate the map from the key and send
them to different continents or better
yet why didn't they simply destroy the
mapping key one thing you may have not
noticed during your first second or even
third viewing is that when Evie's boss
at the Museum in Cairo Dr Terence Bay
accidentally lights the map on fire and
burns after location of hamanuptra he's
actually performing his duties at the
Magi to keep the location a secret
although the mummy is a nostalgic film
for a lot of us who saw it as children
or teens there are some questionable
things you might not have noticed during
your first viewing one problematic
aspect of the film is that many of the
ethnic characters are depicted as
one-dimensional racial stereotypes R.F
Bay is treated with respects and
gravitas but this proves to be a
somewhat unique representation overall
according to a writer from cracked it is
and has always been aggressively racist
the writer calls out the franchise for
its questionable choices saying there
isn't a single Mana person and a lead
role in the mummy and the supporting
roles are stoked with actors of various
nationalities playing Arabs who are
usually offensive caricatures this is
especially the case with the character
of the warden God Hassan played by actor
Omid julili who's often the butt of
racist jokes in the film
smelly little friend jalily told
entertainment's weekly that because of
his Iranian background he felt a way to
representing Middle Eastern culture he
asked director Stephen Summers look why
don't we play him differently because
with all due respect to you what you've
written is not even one dimensioner I
can possibly get this to a
two-dimensional stereotype and then
there's a matter of casting the ancient
high priest imagep with a white actor
whoops in 2019 Arnold vosloo taught
Entertainment Weekly I always wonder if
it were happening today would I get the
part I mean here I am white South
African that probably cast a real
Egyptian The Mummy includes a group of
Americans Mr Henderson Mr Daniels and Mr
Burns who are traveling to harmonaptura
and they're not depicted in the most
glowing light either you're looking for
Herman after him damn straight we are
who says we are he does
Evie and Jonathan who grew up in the UK
both make derive comments about the
Americans at their dig sites before
telling Rick no offense Almost Doesn't
afterthought
and okay perhaps it's called for in this
case these Americans after all are grave
robbers it feels like the digs are a
good nated way to poke fun at Americans
International reputation for being
terrible Taurus the first time you see
the Americans depicted as nutty yahoos
as in a gun battle with the Magi
Warriors
they Hoot and Holler and fire their six
shooters with Reckless abandon while the
barge Burns around them the Americans
and Barrel ahead at the dig site and
open the chest despite the warnings of
Benny and the egyptologist Dr Alan
Chamberlain after Emma teb hunts him
down in order to suck them dry to
restore his flesh and power the
Americans proved to be all blister with
little bravery to back it up after
taking Mr Burns eyes and tongue it might
set mistake CV for a nuk sumanoon it
might seem like emotep is just totally
obsessed with us to cease Paramore but
after watching the mummy a few times it
becomes clear this is a gag referring to
Mr Burns poor eyesight when we first
meet Mr Burns on the barge his
compatriots give him a hard time but
playing with your glasses and cut the
dead would you burn walk out my glasses
I can't see the deck to cut it can I
Daniel so Imhotep took Burns eyes and
tongue and since he's rebuilding his
body from the Americans organs it makes
sense that until immotep is fully
regenerated and has his ancient Egyptian
mojo back he might be nearsighted like
his very first organ donor nearly
everyone headed to Herman Opera is a
grave robber who takes no moral or
ethical issue with stealing from the
dead or another culture greed motivates
Jonathan Warden gut Hassan is driven by
avarice as our Benny and the Americans
Dr Alan Chamberlain seems to be a
serious archaeologist but the way he
cradles The Book of the Dead after
finding it with the canopic draw suggest
that he too covet's treasure on the
barge Evie is impressed that Rick knows
the book of a Monroe was rumored to be
made of pure gold you know your history
I know my treasure this 1920s Egyptian
treasure fever is historically accurate
few Egyptian tombs made it to monundity
without being raided even King
Tutankhamun's tomb have been partially
pillaged before it was discovered by
British archaeologists Howard Carter and
his financer Lord carnavan in 1922.
however recent evidence suggests that
Carter may have actually been the one to
disturb the tomb before its official
opening but Evie's not looking to line
her Pockets she wants to know more about
ancient Egypt and hopes to fill museums
not a bank account with riches
fortunately the mummy doesn't celebrate
greed the film's messages are looting
the country of its history and wealth is
decidedly not good and most of the
characters who do so end up dying
horribly a Scarab crawls under Warden
guard Hassan's skin and eats him from
the inside out imotep sucks the
Americans and the egyptologists dry
leaving behind shell-like hersks Benny
gets eaten alive by scarabs after the
Crypt self-destructs and then there's
Jonathan well I guess we go home
empty-handed again ultimately Jonathan's
rewarded with saddle bags full of
treasure because he overcame his greed
to help Rick save Evie and send Imhotep
back to the underworld and although Rick
Begins the film was a questionable
character who's interested first and
foremost in finding treasure when the
chips are down he doesn't run away even
though he wants to in the end Rick Evie
Jonathan and ardef band together and
walk away from all that glittering gold
in the treasure room instead they take
responsibility for their parting
resurrecting immotep and does this
refusal to let their greed win that sees
them rewarded in the end on multiple
viewings of the Mummy you might realize
the immotep having the power of the 10
plagues of Egypt doesn't quite add up in
the book of Exodus God unleashes 10
plagues including Locus blood and boils
upon Egypt because the Pharaoh refuses
to let Moses as people go more the
identity of that Pharaoh has been
debated most people believe that it
refers to Ramses II the successor of
King seti the first in the world of the
Mummy that means that Imhotep gets
cursed with the hum die before the 10
plagues are Unleashed upon Egypt which
creates a bit of a historical plot hole
and frogs
flies locusts anything but you
compared to you the other plagues were a
joy Locus swore Mama nabtra right after
Evie resurrects Emma tap from reading
the book of the Dead which confirms that
emote said this a power to bring the ten
plagues of Egypt with him although we
see many of the plagues including
locusts flies hail and Eerie eclipse and
Jonathan's favorite boils we don't see
or turn maybe the frogs lice and
livestock pestilence happen somewhere
outside of Cairo while burning hail
destroyed the city luckily for Jonathan
the last and perhaps most devastating
plague the death of firstborn Sons never
materializes Evie might start out the
mummy is a librarian but she's an
adventurer at heart you're wondering
what is a place like me doing in a girl
like this the more times you watch it
the more you realize how her character
isn't restricted by gender Norms or
genre tropes when the water makes an
Indecent Proposal or bargaining for
Rick's life Evie smacks his hand away
and negotiates a smaller share of the
treasure for Rick's release and Evie is
also the most distinguished in her
career amongst the core characters Emma
am I librarian Evie knows Egyptian
history and Archeology and both Jonathan
and Rick respect that she is in charge
of the dick site she isn't just feisty
and smart she's nearly Fearless the
weird noises in harmony don't frighten
her because she's not superstitious and
after evc's image step and accepts that
he's real she refuses to run away
instead Evie insists they deal with
emotep because she is the one who set
him free although there are points in
the film where it looks like Evie's
being painted as a damsel in distress
Rick even calls her one to Winston she
consistently pushes against this what
what'd I say there are disconcerting
moments such as Rick kissing her without
consent and locking her in a room to
protect her from immotep but Evie pushes
back when the immotep takes Evie hostage
she goes with him willingly in order to
save everyone from his Zombies She's an
integral part of the team rather than a
two-dimensional love interest in service
of the male hero
[Music]